For this problem, we ask about the missing step in garbled circuits as covered in Unit 7.
At the end of the garbled circuit protocol, the evaluator has the output wire labels
x1 through xn.
The generator knows the corresponding semantic values.
For notation x10  is the wire label corresponding to a semantic value of 0 for wire 1
and x11 is the wire label corresponding to semantic value of 1 for wire 1.
Suppose the generator want to reveal the result to the evaluator
without revealing any other wire labels.
Which of these five options would allow the evaluator to correctly determine
the semantic value of the were label x1 and not reveal the other output wire label?
Check all that apply.